[Music]
how's it going everyone mark madden rip
here and we're back at the playstation
competition center for more tekken 7
videos
today we're going to talk about walls
and how it'll change your strategy in a
fight
most stages in tekken are small
battlefield surrounded on all sides by
walls
as you bike you may get pushed towards
one of these boundaries and find itself
trapped between your opponent and the
wall
like being cornered in most 2d fighting
games this is a very bad spot to be in
and you'll want to avoid getting in this
position as best you can
normally when you're being pressured in
tekken you can back dash away from your
opponent to create space
when you're near a wall that option no
longer exists not only that but many
attacks in tekken 7 that are normally
pretty innocent
will cause what's called a wall splat
when you hit someone towards the wall
these moves now suddenly become high
damage combo starters making a lot of
attacks very scary
how do you defend with your back to the
wall first it's very important to wait
for your turn then slowly try to use
your side step to get away from the wall
next try not to crouch at the back of
the wall as most attacks the wall splat
you will be mid-attacked
this will lead to another combo and
leave you in the same situation patience
and timing will be key
another important tactic is to use
throws while near the wall
knowing your throw range and how they
manipulate the positioning between you
and your opponent is key
certain throws will allow you to swap
places between you and your opponent
regardless if they were successful or
escaped keep this knowledge in mind when
you're looking for an opportunity to
escape the danger zone near a walled
area of the state
on offense if you are hitting your
opponent in the air towards a wall
sometimes the wall splatter will occur
at an unexpected time or angle and cause
the rest of your combo to not work
properly
when you're first starting out don't
worry about this too much but as you
play more you'll start to recognize
where you are in the stage and realize
how to adjust your combo
to account for the wall distance
of course some stages in tekken 7 do not
have any walls at all
these are usually called infinite stages
and benefit certain playstyles that
don't rely on using the walls
and on some stages certain walls can
actually break if you hit your opponent
into them the right way
your opponent might even fall down to a
new part of the stage giving you new
combo opportunities
it's important to keep in mind at all
times where the walls are on offense you
want to push your opponents towards the
wall
and on defense you want to use your
movement to get yourself away from the
wall
that's it for this episode this tutorial
is made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can check out
compete.playstation.com to watch learn
and compete
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials and tekken 7 content